just and we're talking about 100 to 200
sometimes even three in milliseconds
we're putting together all of this
cognitive stuff that goes into what I
will be calling deep breathing in a
minute
but what I want you to think about is
that what we are doing is not unlike and
I look at Ryan my English PhD we are
doing exactly what Proust had said in
this tiny little book called on reading
which nobody reads and interestingly
terribly he said it better than any
teacher neuroscientist or linguist that
what we do when we read is that we go to
the end of the wisdom of the author and
move into our oh this is my profit Ori
way of talking about what I am calling
deep reading skills it's essential for
you in this tiny moment with me to
recognize what you do when you move from
three to four hundred milliseconds and
if we're an evoked potential territory
those of you in psychology this is the
end 400 moment this is the moment when
you pull together what you know about
the word with what you know from the
world you put your perspective of other
your perspective taking your imagery and
then you move through analogy to
inferential processes these processes
make you think completely differently
you are for all purposes her cube for
our role you are sure like you are Miss
Marple but you are doing something to
that information that changes it and
from that change comes critical analysis
and very very importantly if we are
lucky if you know to allocate time this
is unconscious but this is if we are
trained to do this we move into proofs
territory where we move
to our own if you will global neuronal
workspace where we think beyond the
author and we generate new thoughts
[Music]